welcome everyone who's coming in i'll
try to be too repetitive repetitive as
more people come in i'll just
welcome everyone here if everyone
i know ahmad i just mentioned if you can
go into the slack channel
and um join the july 28th meetup
channel this way we could find you all
you know the slack team is a growing
slack community
with lots of channels to find help about
r or python even git and julia
we had someone post actually um
and i'm trying to connect them with the
head of the julia meetup
i'm just trying to dig that up and we
have all sorts of stuff that we announce
events both about our community and
other communities
it's a lot of good stuff happening in
there
i'm just sitting at six o'clock march
like old people will be
um able to come in so a lot of them are
gonna be picking up
i might have found a way to have a link
directly to the channel which i have
still not figured out how to do so thank
you for doing that amada
hopefully it works but you definitely
have to join um and my hacker first
all right and um folks you just have to
join and we have
seen there steve now saying um hello
from boston where it's 93 degrees
i'm not sure what it is anywhere else
but i know it's hot everywhere in the
northeast right now
now steven how boston or like boston
area
are you really coming from newton or
cambridge or
one of those other places
maybe that place starts at an s i can't
remember
downtown oh you're right across the
south station nice area
at least normally not sure how i'm not
sure how it is during the pandemic
that's a great part of town
i can imagine it's quiet
um so if someone is asking uh there is
audio on for attendees you should be
able to get
audio to hear the speakers
uh but not to actually speak yourselves
but you cannot hear
myself this is going to actually you're
not going to hear me so i'm out of you
could put in the
the chat saying that they could always
dial into their phone if they can't hear
me
uh and but their world attendees can't
chat okay
uh utah someone's coming from utah i've
only ever spent two nights in utah i was
in salt lake city but they were really
nice
two nights great food a great beer scene
i really enjoyed the
brewery at brewery i went to uh irab hi
uh iran and utah
they only saw in your name i just say
emi but now iran makes a lot more sense
you're not in salt lake city you're
cities i can't remember the name of but
you know
park city that's it enjoy it
all right great
i'm gonna mute my notifications
all right we're starting to get a bit of
a critical mass we'll slowly get started
with
um some of the announcements we usually
make
i'll repeat some of these as people come
in so first up welcome
so everyone is here i said welcome a
bunch of times i will continue to say
welcome to everyone trickling it
uh it's very great to have you for what
is now i believe our fourth virtual
meetup
yep our fourth one uh we've these things
have been going strong so we
we got our last in-person meet up right
before most of the country went to
lockdown
um luckily i haven't heard of anyone uh
falling ill
and is our fourth virtual one we have
been lucky to get speakers from all
around the world that's the bright side
instead of just people who are
passing through new york or living in
new york or the area we're having
speakers from all over the world as we
have tonight
so one thing we are not able to do as
much when we are virtual because no one
can shout out in this group
is jobs who is hiring but
fortunately in the slack channel and the
slack team a model linked to
we have a channel called called job
postings
and this is good all year round whether
there's a pandemic or not if you have a
job you want to announce
go to job postings job dash postings
if you're looking for a job go to job
dash postings
to find the jobs well hopefully that
collision with people who are hiring and
people who are looking for jobs will
meet there
so we've gotten many jobs through this
meetup so i'm very always super excited
whenever we can get someone else a job
uh another thing um we can't do any more
in person
i hope everyone's doing individually is
pizza
so i got my slice this month from a
place called kanti's
c-o-n-t-e apostrophe s you can see here
it's a super thin crust
very hard has good cheese lock the
cheese is not sliding right off the
plate
some good charring on the back you can
tell it's a gas oven
uh so that's very interesting a gas oven
is probably the most typical type of
oven
it makes her good but most people think
of as northeastern pizza
so hopefully everyone has their own
slice if anyone does did get their own
pizzas as encouraged
shout out in the slack channel let us
know where you're eating from always fun
to see where different people are
getting pizza from
we love seeing that so hopefully you can
enjoy this
with us i know i always enjoy the pizza
at least
next month is our big month of our
events
uh we have the our conference august
12th through 15th
we're really excited about that we're
working really hard ahmad here has been
working non-stop
trying to make this not just a bunch of
talking heads on a screen we have some
things in store for you if you're coming
that you'll see we're not going to tell
you right now so they're meant to be
some surprises
they're going to make it more
interactive than just the plain virtual
conference
if you want to learn more you go to
rstats.ai a lot of you can put that in
the chat um
rstats.ai and since you're members of
this meetup and the conference is really
meant to be an algorithm for the
community that's how it got started
six years ago i said to some friends
let's have a two-day party about r
and some people let me do it uh so since
you're part of this community and are
really
out of this community uh you can use the
code ny
hack r for 20 discount on the conference
and the workshops we have about i think
seven different workshops spread across
two days max kuhn is already sold out
but we still have david robinson
teaching the tidy verse
cass akamoto teaching gis dan chen
teaching
um we have
amanda dabin teaching arvest we have i
know i'm going to forget someone here i
know we have vivian peng teaching shiny
we have another one which is escaping me
we also have andreas mueller believe it
or not teaching scikit-learn
yes we are having a python machine
learning workshop at the r conference
because this community
remember it is the open statistical
programming you know your r and friends
we've had talks on python on julia on go
on sql
there it is and i did not leave anybody
out yes thankfully i did not leave
anybody out i mean i might have just
posted an image on the slack channel
again ny hack r gets you 20 off
of the workshops as well and they're a
lot of fun i've seen a bunch of these
workshops before
i've even taken andre well i've sat in
on andreas's workshop to heckle him a
little bit as the r person
but i've been in almost all these
workshops at various points um
very excited to have these going on
remember the workshops are august 12-13
and the conference itself is august
14-15 in
our speaker lineup we have andrew gilman
we have e-rob who's here
we have uh max [ __ ] we have david smith
we have um heather and jacqueline
knowles we have both notices
it's going to be a lot of fun many more
people i'm not even um saying the names
of there's too many hills them all
it's going to be a lot of fun and as has
become
our tradition for the conference we have
a meet up the week of the conference
also just make it more work for us
so that monday august 10th we have miles
mcbain
coming to us from australia i believe
talking about drake
uh this all started because he posted
something on twitter i asked him a lot
of
questions on twitter about how do i use
drake how help and he helped me out so
much
so i emailed him and said no good deed
goes unpunished
do you want to give a talk at the meet
up now he happily agreed
so he is our our week speaker this time
he'll be speaking monday then the
conference is wednesday through saturday
so that will be announced hopefully
tomorrow
on august 10th we'll have miles of fame
talking about drake
as for the for the meetup as part of the
conference
i would like to thank um ecohealth
alliance for
giving us the zoom link this month and
every month so far
um and not just equal health alliance
but
also noam ross he has been our helper
there so everyone
give a virtual applause for noah many
global lines for helping us out thank
you very much
also i'd like to thank scott's pizza
tours for uh
giving 20 discount codes to all members
of the meetup
i know the code is supposed to work
through july but if all of a sudden a
lot of you use it
i can ask him to extend it he's been
sponsoring the meetup for the past few
months
giving virtual pizza tours um colin is
new to our community here
you see how obsessed at least i am with
pizza and how i impose that on
the group every month we typically have
pizza from different place and we have
people voted on a pizza pool
uh so we're very excited about that i'm
really into pizza in case there wasn't
obvious
as we are going um tonight's meetup
please ask the questions in the slack
channel if you do it in the in the
slack and put chat i'll see it but it's
much easier for me
you put into the slack channel i will
collate all the questions and i will ask
colin
questions at the end we found that's the
best way to get questions to the speaker
so please go ahead and ask the questions
in the
slack channel that amada sent out and
i'll ask them at the end
afterwards people feel free to hang
around if you want to
ask questions in the slack channel we
call hang out get a virtual happy hour
we tried it in the passive video you
know we can't do video and zoom with
everybody but we do a chatting happy
hour whatever you would like
so all that just a reminder jobs in the
jobs channel
enjoy your pizza the meetup and
conference next month
august 10th and 12th through 15th use my
hacker for your discount code
miles mcvayne will be our meetup speaker
thank you equal health alliance thank
you scott's pizza tours
and coming all the way from france a
special treat please welcome colin and
i'll give a virtual pause right here
thank you very much gone
thanks okay so
i'm going to start by sharing my screen
and unfortunately i don't have
any pizza because you know it's midnight
in france so
i've eaten my dinner a few hours back
so i'm just gonna present
uh too much tonight
topic which is um testing
shiny before sending it to production
let me
share this i'm gonna turn off my videos
so
the bandwidth is better
okay so we are here um today to talk
about
um testing shiny with
the title everything not tested will
eventually
fail so first of all a little
presentation about
a little thing about me so i work
in a company called fincard so we are in
france
in france and we are focused on
everything around data science and data
engineering
with r i also do a lot of open source
work and i'm
not oblivious developer for the
golem project the golem is a project for
building shiny applications that will be
then
sent to production so a few links
here so if you want to complain about
what i'm going to say please reach me on
twitter
if you want to follow some of my open
source work
it's on github and i also have
a website where i
blog about are in engineering
engineering stuff engineering stuff
around r
so finkar finkar is a company which does
data science engineering mainly focused
on r as
its name suggests so we do
we do training we do software
engineering around r
we do r in production and we do
consulting
so software engineering and r in
production
includes building
shiny applications that are then sent
into production
and consulting also means that we audit
some shiny applications that needs to be
sent
that need to be sent to production so
these two these three
things that we do software engineering
are in production consulting involves
um writing tests for uh
these shiny applications but we sent
production
so we have uh
some experience on it so this is why
this is what i'm going to
be talking about uh today
so everything not tested will eventually
fail services talk about
how to write and how to build your tests
uh for shiny application before sending
them to production so i chose this
title because i think that when we today
talk about
testing shiny we focus on some specific
things
and not on some others so some things
are some shiny apps are sent
to production without testing
some of the important sites of
shiny application in production
so little aside before i start so i like
to
remind what we mean by production
so what does production even
mean so what i mean when i say
production is that for me a piece of
software
is in production if it's used even
if it's by only one
person so even even if you have an
application that is used
by only one person uh
as far as i'm concerned it's in
production if
it's also relied upon and as real life
impact so what i mean is that
an application even used by one person
would rely relies on this
application to do the job to take
decisions to
do yeah to do their daily job and to
make decisions based on the output of
this application
is a piece of software that is in
production
so we regularly hear that
when we hear the term production we hear
like
big data and scaling to uh
billions of users and things like that
but i think that's
that hides
a side of production which is smaller
pieces of software
that are used by smaller groups that
needs
this piece of stuff these pieces of
software
for doing their daily job so if you go
to
any company which is not a software
engineering company
they have like softwares
the software they use on a daily basis
which
possibly have been built by
by a software engineering company
especially for them so maybe
just a couple just a handful of people
are using this software but it's still
something which is in production
so it's software that which is
relied upon by the user but also by the
developer so if you are
if you are developing a software
that that is to be sent to production
you rely
on this software to be available to be
accurate
to be modular and to be resilient let's
say that
if things go wrong you need to be able
to catch
the bug to fix them and of course
for you as a developer it has real life
impact because you are working
on this software and if something goes
wrong it's going to have
it's going to have some impact on your
job
so what is the current current state of
unit test so there are more or less
two states of unit test which is that
people don't write any test
so basically of course
a software which has no unit test can't
fail because there are no
unit tests and the other side is
people who write too many tests so
that people that spend hours and hours
of development time writing
tests and maybe something other people
that are in the middle of i don't know
if they are
writing good code or bad unit tests
so first of all why
would you want to test your shiny
application
before sending it into production
i like this image about unit test
which is titanic and um
it so all these little
parts passed the unit test so it's a
good metaphor for everything that's not
tested will eventually break
so if you send something
into production if you if you send your
boat
on the c and you have tested
only some parts of your application
chances are that all the parts
will at some point in time crack so
when a software break that means that
maybe you are on call and you are the
one
who is going to have to fix this these
bugs
also um a good code from jenny bryan
we said
if you are writing a software that has
no unit tests
you let your users be your unit tests
that is to say that
if you are writing a software if you're
writing a shiny application
you send it to production and people
stops using it and you don't have
written any unit test you expect the
people to find
the bugs in your software so it's
depending of course on the context of
the development and on
the people who are using the application
but it's
really a bad user experience to have
a new software at work that you rely on
on to do your job that you are going to
use on a daily basis and every time you
open it
it fails or every time you try to
every time you try to do something it
just crashes
so if you are not
writing any unit test you are
expecting you your users to find them
and to come to you and to complain about
them
also another thing that
is sometimes forgotten about
test is testing how many resources
your application is going to need
so basically you are writing a shiny
application
on your computer and you have
a macbook or i don't know with something
like
16 gigabytes of ram and the application
works and you don't really think about
how many resources it takes to run your
application on your computer
but that's something that is different
when you have to send
your application to production because
your application is going to run on
someone else's
computer most of the time on
i don't know an nws or google cloud
platform
or maybe you have a server with askview
connect
or ask your server or something like
that and
that means that this application will
run on a server with
limited resources with resources that
costs
that cost money so
this is something that is regularly
forgotten when it comes to
testing shiny it's how many resource
my how many resources my
application need and
a little story about um
about testing shiny so i've put recently
i've audited
a shiny application which i put to
our r studio connect server
and i did a typo when i launched my
load test and instead of
so i wanted to mimic the behavior of 50
people and i
typed 500
so basically it mimicked 500 connections
to the shiny app
on my r studio connect
server and basically it
crashed the server and i created a
denial of service on my own server
by testing this application but what
that means
is that if you if i had put this
application
on my server without controlling
the load and controlling these kind of
things
if ever that much people
had tried to connect to my application
my
server would have crashed so basically i
received this application
to audit it and to optimize it
and i ended up doing a denial of service
on my own
server so
so why testing your application so for
two stage
two stages during development you want
to test because you want to
safely collaborate and you want to be
able to change
things on a project safely
so making changes to a project into a
code base
should be pain-free but to say that you
shouldn't be scared to
change something and to break something
because if something breaks
bugs are detected if they are tested
and of course a good
testing strategy on your shiny
application allows
new people to come and to work and to
try things
because we can try to change we can try
to
to change the code base to move things
and
as long as the tests are still running
correctly
we are sure that they are working
correctly on the project also in
production it also means that you are
safely serving your application because
your user should not be your unit test
as i said before
you should think that serving an
application costs money
so you shouldn't spend one million bucks
on rws because i think jeff bezos is
rich enough so you should try to lower
your expense and try to not
do a certain try not to clutter your
server with
too many resources needed by your shiny
applicants
shiny applications so this is something
that you should
think up front before sending your
application
to to production
so second part in the y
let's talk about the what so
the first thing that
you are going to want to test and the
first thing that
a lot of people focus on is testing the
user interface so the using interface
refers to
what the users see what they interact
with the general design
of your application and
my advice regarding user interface
testing is that if your time is
limited and changes chances are that
your time will be limited when doing a
shiny project
if you have to choose don't focus too
much
on pure user interface so
don't focus too much on testing the
user interface why
because i think the most important thing
to test in a shiny application even more
in the context
of of a shiny app where
we are designing applications to
analyze data and to make production
or to build crafts or to build
things that will help other people take
decisions
so this business logic in the context of
data science product is very important
because you should be certain
that this part of your application
is accurate but it's
it returns the correct results
the correct craft so hold this
the core algorithms that makes your
application unique
um all these functions that
contain your business knowledge or this
function
that produce results
that your users are going to rely on
these
are the function you should in the first
time
be focusing on so if you have to
prioritize your testing strategy
i think you should first spend time on
testing this business logic
as extensively as possible
and finally the third thing which is
something
which is regularly forgotten is the
application load
because um
poor out performance leads to a bad user
experience and
potentially it costs money
so when i talk about application load is
how many
cpu ram does your application need
because if you are not able to
estimate this it will lead to a slow
application so people are going to try
to connect but the
shiny application will be very slow
shiny application won't produce any
results the graph
will take a long time to render and
basically at some point
they are going to stop
using your application because the
performance
performances are too bad um and this is
actually something
important to know upfront because
it's not the same to build a shiny
application
that is going to be deployed for one
people
for 10 people all for thousands of
people
we usually hear that
you know shiny doesn't scale or
we hear on the other hand that
javascript scales well
or that other languages scale
well but the thing is that for example
facebook they didn't use so they had
uh facebook had specific uh requirements
when it comes to scaling so they started
writing their own version of javascript
and the own
backend languages just to
be able to manage the load via
the the need so
why am i saying that i'm saying that
because
if your application needs to scale you
need to know it
up front because writing
an application for a small amount of
people is not the same as
writing an application for
thousands and thousands of users for
example
if you have an application that serves
to a thousand
of people you might
want to put the data inside your
application because
the data takes a small amount of ram and
it's
it still can be managed by the server
but
if your application need to scale to
thousands of people you are not going to
put your
data set inside your application you are
going to use
an external database and something with
high performance and something that you
can
make a lot of requests on
very quickly so this application load if
you are building an application but need
to scale it's very important
to anticipate it
so how do we do that how do we test
all things
what i've just said
first of all how to test
the business logic or the backings of
your application
so this is something that is easily done
if you follow
the idea of building shiny apps as a
package so this is
um this is something which is supported
by
the golem framework so when you build a
shiny application
using the column framework you are
building your
shiny app as a package and one of
the big idea behind building showing up
as a package
is that you should try to separate
as much as possible the business logic
from the interactive logic
that is to say that all the core
algorithms of
your application should be written as
standard our function
why because it allows to leverage
all the things that have been created
along the years for building robust
packages so be it the
documentation be it the
dependency management but also
for the testing you can
leverage the standard testing frameworks
to
test this business logic this back end
of
your application so for example if you
are building a shiny application
as a package you can use the
test that tesla package so the desert
package allows you to write
a series of expectations so you write
contexts and expectations for example
in my in my example i have a function
called
meaning of life so let's say that
meaning of life is one of my core
core backend functions and i'm
expecting this function to return 42
every time i call it so the idea is that
when the user when the users are going
to
use the application they are going to
expect
this result
so here i'm writing a test
today with my back-end function that
returns
42 and i'm sure that this is what i want
today and and then i mean six months
because
you know when you are working on a
production
application it might take
a long time so if in six months you come
back to your application you change
this function and it know it's return i
don't know 43
you are sure that you are going to catch
this change so which
this change might be the
correct one so maybe it's maybe you want
this function to change but at least
you are sure that you are catching this
change and
in that inside the next version of
your application you are going to make
the changes
and it's a deliberate
change not a bug
so this for the back-end testing the
back-end with
testvat which is a standard
testing framework for our function so i
said writing
shiny app as a package allow you to
leverage all these things
but you will also want to test the
user interface or the front end
and for that i'm going to present three
tools so shiny tests which
test visual regression of your
application
puppeteer which is a command line
tool written in node.js
that drives an atlas chrome
session and marks a connection to your
application
and interactions and um
another package in r which is
inspired by by what puppeteer
does which is called cry which is a tool
to drive
a shiny session from the common line
and to interact
with this shiny session because
puppeteer
can connect to any
web page because it's not specific to
shiny nor to r
it's really specific to javascript
so shiny tests first shiny test
it allows you to record snapshots of an
app
so snapshots of the state of your
application
so how it works is that you are
launching your application
you are taking snapshots of your
application
at given moment so at
specific moment
at specific moments then you can change
things and you can replay
the application and then you can detect
if there are any visual regression
inside your application so it's really
focused
on visual
changes so it's really if you want to
detect
things that have changed on the ui
so i don't use shiny tests that much
because i think
this is not
i don't think this is the um
the thing you should be focusing on the
most when building
a shiny test
so i use puppeteer
for some of my tests so it allows you to
record
the interaction
with the application so it then replace
[Music]
so it will launches and it replaces the
interaction
with node.js and then it detects if
there are any application logic changes
so basically instead of detecting that
your your application has visually
changed
it detects that i don't know some
of the button don't work anymore some of
the ui elements are not
available anymore doing this or that
makes the application crash so it
focuses on
replaying the
application logic and not
it doesn't focus on the
purely visual changes so i've written
here
a bit of javascript code so
that does perfectly test so
if you read from top to bottom so first
you load the
puppeteer package then
launch puppeteer and you connect to the
page for example
here i'm connecting to my local host
then once this application is
connected i'm waiting for
something in the dom to be ready and
once it's ready
i'm clicking on it and
then i close the connection so it's a
small and
it's not a real life test but
it's just so that you get the logic so
basically the idea is to
repeat the actions you are
performing with your application from
the common line and so you don't focus
on
visual changes you focus on
interactive logic and
the cool thing is that it has a chrome
extension
so it has a chrome extension and then
what it does is that you click on record
and it
records it returns the node.js code
to replay the application so you start
the recording
you interact with your application and
then you can replay this code from
node.js
without having to launch
anything manually so you don't have to
launch any browser you don't have to do
the test yourself
so in the same spirit um the package
called
cry which is a wrapper around another
package called
cree in french so it's
a remote it it's
it's um this this first package cree
is for doing remote orchestration of
chrome
and cry as specific recipes for shiny
apps so basically
the idea is to connect to a shiny app
and to interact with it
and of course the idea is to have
everything
scripted so this is
what it looks like so you are creating a
new testing session
with you can use page down find chrome
to find the chrome
binary then you connect this chrome
binary to a random
pose and then you go to a web page so it
can be
something online or it can be something
on your local machine then you wait for
shiny to be ready so
you launch the app you connect to it you
launch the test
the test launch the test launches chrome
chrome connects to the url and you wait
for
shiny to be ready to receive inputs
then for example here
um can use a for loop to set
a values for a given input here i have
an input
with this long id so it's the package
name
in my application xmac and i'm setting
a series of letters for that
in input and every time i run this shiny
set
input cry checks that
shiny is still working so the idea is
for example here to
do some kind of
brute force of input in the sense that
you can set
a series of inputs here is the letters
but it could be
like random letters or random words or
random numbers just to check that if
you set your input with this value the
application still
works
and another cool
libraries to do
to test your interactive logic is called
gremlins so it's a javascript library
that
simulates the halls of grimlin using an
app so the idea is that
if you click on this so you can install
it
as an extension to your browser and it
simulates
random clicks and random scrolls on your
application so it allows to
detect if your application is able to
manage unexpected behaviors so it's
kind of of a funny extension because
just like those random things and just
you are able to anticipate unexpected
behaviors of your application
and so this is included in cry
so you can do it from your browser if
you want because it's like it's kind of
funny to watch but
you can also use inside cry
the function called gremlins hold
so it launches these halls of gremlin
that
interacts at random with your
application
so you have to let it perform
its work for a couple of seconds and
then you can check that your application
is
still working so this is for testing the
interactive logic of your application
finally testing your application load so
shiny load tests so it's a native r
package with a command line and tool to
record and replay
a shiny session and to perform load
tests
another package called docker stats
which
allows to get the stats for a docker
container
inside r as a data frame so
it allows you to for example tokyo stats
as
a column called memory usage so if you
want to test the ram
needed by specific application inside
the container
it can be used and of course you can
combine
cry and docker start or even shiny load
test and docker stats
so shiny load tests it records a visit
to the application and then it will
replay the app
with multiple users and it gives
some detailed stats about
response time and load so
the very nice thing is that you really
have these
detailed data about
how your application responded to
these numerous users it can be used
on your local machine or what you can do
you can
make shiny load
connect to an application deployed on
your server
and you can then record and analyze
these data the only downside
i have found with shiny load test so far
is that you have to
manually record the first session but
you see that you have to launch
the session recording you have to
manually
click and interact with your app before
before being able to do the load test
so docker stats what it does
is that it's a wrapper around the common
lined
talker stats and basically it takes
the stats from you from docker and
it turns it into an r data frame it can
be called
recursively that you see that you can
launch a function called tokistat
um
uh docusatricus and it launches the
function recursively that's like every
second
it records the docker stats
so that for example you launch
this docker stats function which is
recursive and it records
the stats for your containers
every second you interact with your
application be it
manually or with a script and then at
the end of your session
you have this data frame in r
that you can analyze and which you can
plot you can analyze the for example the
memory
usage
how it works sorry about
printing so you are
running the container for example here
i'm launching a container
and you call docker stats docker stat
i had an issue when compiling my
compiling my slides because probably i
had turned off
docker but basically it returns here
when you call
this function it returns
a data frame
with all the data for example you can be
interested in the memory usage
the cpu usage
and the time of record yeah i as you can
see
i have a message saying unable to find
any container running
so that's because i had turned off
my docker engine before compiling these
slides
of course what's interesting is to um
combine it for example we cry so i'm
getting the results from the first
launch
on the container and then i'm setting a
series of later
letters for
my input and every time i'm setting this
input i'm
binding the result to
the current recording so the current
state
of my container
which can lead to
these this kind of graph which
allows you to watch how the
memory usage evolves
in time so here on the x
axis i have the record time so you can
see that
at launch my container takes
this amount of ram
and setting the first input
makes my
memory usage jump and then i'm pretty
stable when i
change this input so it allows you to
watch your memory usage for a given
container over time
so to conclude um
test often and test soon as soon as
possible
um if you have to choose
uh focus on the back end because
if you spend too much time focusing on
the ui
you won't have any time to focus on the
back end but the backing is
at the end of the day the back end is
what matters most when
when i say back end it's the core
algorithm
what makes your application unique
and it's also the things that
your users are going to rely on it's
like it kind of doesn't matter if
uh a button has changed from from
uh i don't know pink to blue but it does
matter
that a function returns 4 43
when it's supposed to return 42 so
yeah if you have to choose focus on
the back end
and interactive tests can and should be
scripted as much as possible and
of course don't forget to test
the load of your application before
sending it into
production so series of links
so i'm going to put these slides online
so if you want to
find all the tools i've presented you
can click
the link and of course
these things are described in more
detail
in facebook we've been
writing which is called engineering
production grade shiny apps
it's available online for free it's
going to be available in print
in a few months you can find it on
engineering.shiny.org and if you want
more details about
these methods you'll find
you'll find them here and
thank you and now is the time for
questions
thank you very much for that
presentation um hope everyone had a
great time listening to it so let's just
say
again a virtual round of applause for
colin
uh for you know i spoke at a conference
a few months ago
at e-rom and they had like a virtual
applause machine like so they could make
applause noise yeah
right yeah you were there i think i got
i got to figure out where they got that
machine from
and you know that wasn't machine it was
just like a file on the computer i've
got to find it so i could do that for
our speakers
there must be you know a smartphone
application to do that
oh that's probably all was it probably
had their phone i thought it was like
some
plug-in for the computer it's probably
just a phone all right fine i'm gonna go
get that
i'm gonna find go do it do that thank
you for that idea
okay so we have a few questions
the first up is is test that your
favorite testing package and if so
why do you find it so useful
um it's
it's my favorite because i say that it's
the one i know the most
so i couldn't speak for the other
testing frameworks i don't know them
that well
but i know it's like the most widely
widely
widely used so i don't know it's the one
i know
so i i
i i don't prefer it's over i know
i like i'm just the one i know so yeah
i say the same thing for me because i
know there's r unit and there's tiny
test
but test that's the one i know as well
because it's one of the easier ones to
pick up at least
in my mind uh
regarding the memory test from the
docker stats
it looked like the memory went up and
down up and down
that's what i assumed the vertical lines
were did
i know that typically r doesn't release
memory back to the operating system
so how do you get the drops in memory
from a docker process
oh yes i know it's it's not to drop so
the vertical lines
are uh new events so setting a new input
it's not
like a memory okay so basically the line
goes up and it's pretty flat
and theoretically can only keep going up
might spike but it'll never go down
yeah so v vertical line are just a new
event so setting a new
input inside shiny so it's not like in
memory doing that
okay so you might be interested in like
h to i it went up
you know that's though that's something
that
yeah
which i i um i don't know i just like
take the
it just like takes the memory from
docker so i don't know what
you know what is going on behind behind
it just like snapshots the memory
from the container and typically r won't
release back and i guess
the docker container is the os at that
point r doesn't usually release memory
unless there's a gc invoked so okay
yeah i just i tested a shiny application
that just goes it
went up up until it reached the limit of
the docker container it just like
freezes my docker engine so yeah yeah
that sounds right it can it can happen
do you put most of your shiny apps into
docker containers
that depends um i
i love docker use it on a daily basis
but that depends
where it is to be deployed so yeah if
if it is to be deployed on um
yeah aws google cloud or shiny proxy or
things like that i put them in docker
container but
if it needs to be deployed for example
in connect i can put them into docker
because connect
doesn't expect a docker container so
that depends on where
the application has to be deployed
um there's a question asking are there
profiling tools that show where the code
is spending its time
yeah uh so there are there is um
so prof this p-r-o-f-v-i-s
which like is profiling the code so if
you have something
which is slow so it shows a flame graph
with the code so you can like identify
where the code is slow so profits yeah
that's probably the most famous one the
only one that i know of yeah
it's a wrapper around i think it's there
is a base function
that does this thing but it's wrapped
around the um
the base function but what it does is
that it shows a flame graph and
interactive so it's easier to manipulate
you you don't put a lot of emphasis on
testing the ui but if you played with vi
diff
or i think it's called vi diff and or vi
test and how do you
would you integrate that into your flow
to test the uh visuals various plots
yeah i think so as far as i
see it plots are not part of the ui plot
is part of the
business logic of your application
because you know um for example ggplots
can be generated
outside of your shiny app so for me your
ggplot that shows
like a model or trend or the data
i think it's the business logic because
it's part of what makes your application
unique
and yeah it's part for me of a business
logic
so a plotting function will be put
outside of your shiny application and
would
yeah be tested like with uh because it's
v d4 i think uh yeah it might be v diver
yeah all right cool yeah that makes a
good that makes a uh
good sense because that that is logic
and it just gets inserted in
okay yeah yeah what i'm talking about
testing the ui is really if you are
really testing visual things you are
testing you know the colors the size
all the divs and you know
really like web design stuff
you know not the car the car
interface do you ever
use uh custom html or have someone else
build if you're not the person
custom html is the front end instead of
using the shiny ui
components yeah so um
so i've put an example on my youtube
account lately off
i think a couple of weeks back of how to
integrate
an external html template inside shiny
so it uses
a free template from w3
which is a web school so it's
an online website for learning web
technologies
uh yeah we did we did that for our
clients so
the idea is that we hired
a company that does web design and they
created a series of web
bootstrap components and we bind
we binded them to shiny
and then people had so people using
this so it was packaged so we created a
package with
these bootstrap elements which could be
used just like a fluid page
so it had a series of custom action
button
custom page custom slider which was a
binding for these
bootstrap elements
any advice on how to perform shiny app
code review within a small team
love one yeah
um i think
one of yeah one of my main advice maybe
stops
sharing my screen one of my main advice
is ready to
to try to focus on really separating
these
business logic things from the ui
because it
same goes for circuit it works well for
testing but it works well for
code review because if you want to
review someone else's
function you don't have to you know
replay the application
it can be tested even if the app is not
finished
because you know one of the main issue
when you are
if you mix everything in your shiny
application is that if you want to test
the function you have to use
the application but um
yeah i don't know a function that takes
data framework
that does some data manipulation and
that output
jt frame which is then put into a data
table
this score function it should work
outside shiny outside the interactive
logic
so taking these function this function
that
so generate plots and everything so put
them into separate
files and it helps for code review
because you can review
only this function you don't have to
launch the full application
just to check that the function works
yeah i think that that takes some
discipline sometimes but
yeah pays dividends yeah
yeah i see similar
we try to do the same thing but it's
always like i'll just write the quick
two lines in the app and get it done
with
that that hurts you later yeah it's
always a matter of trade-off you know
just like with tests you you might think
yeah i need to test everything but you
have to
take the decision because your time is
limited so you have to choose which part
you are testing
and which parts you are not so yeah it's
always a matter of trade-off
that's why i need a dedicated qa team
and let them do it all right
yeah that doesn't the most unless you
had a giant company mris doing a project
at a giant company
and three people walked over to my desk
and they're like we're the qa team for
this project
what do we need and then they just took
care of it all three people were
assigned to qa oh nice
yeah that doesn't always happen though
that's rare
yeah all right i'll give everyone else a
few more minutes
um there's a few more moments i should
say to see if there's any other
questions
um about this uh one question we do get
and the question is
not necessarily about you particularly
the question is the slides so if you can
provide us the slides we'll post that
from whitehackr.org
sure cool thank you let's go ahead and
correct some typos and
uv pdf that always happens the px i
noticed i was sharing again right
yeah and they're probably sharing and i
love sharing but since it's not
self-contained it makes us very hard for
us to host it
because we need a single file we could
put put up on an s3 bucket
yeah i pre we print it to pdf perfect
and i have a long running feature
request in a v way
to make it work self-contained and he
said he's about to he thinks he's going
to crack it
as he cracks it i'm doing everything in
sharingan
yeah yeah but i think it makes like big
html5
i don't mind like when i do i o slides
they're still 50 megabyte files
but they load right with sharingan if
you have a 20 megabyte file it takes
five minutes to load and that's not
that's not an option
yeah i don't mind 50 megabytes uh we
have another question snuck in at the
wire
uh do any of the testing tools you
talked about besides test that
affect the code coverage detected by
tools like codecov
yeah so um if you are using
um yeah of course if you're using
puppeteer to
interact with your application of course
it's not sketch
by code curve
yeah and i think if you are testing
thing is that
as if you're testing your interactive
logic
you are launching your application in in
another process
and then you are performing actions so
you
don't know what happens in the backend
of this other process so you know which
function
are call a call from this other process
so yeah but that won't help with good
coverage
well let me ask a question um cara was
the question asked
ask her are you talking about the the
stuff that colin focused on like cry
in those tests like shiny test are you
talking about the ones we mentioned
briefly
like our unit because i've been feeling
our unit
might get captured by coconuts i have no
clue and i punt a column but
he doesn't use it that much or are you
talking about cry and shiny test and the
load test stuff
give her a second to reply
i'm like juggling my screen
[Laughter]
talking more about shiny test so like if
it's not like shiny test
could that be captured by kodkov yeah
and not
not as far as i know because it really
launches like shiny in another process
so
as it's another process like we have no
clue about what's happening
inside the this process as far as i know
cool any
other last-minute takers here cause i
know it is getting late for colin
in france uh he's been very gracious uh
doing it even at six o'clock six o'clock
for us we're trying to balance
his sleep but also letting people from
not just new york but the west coast to
10 because since it's virtual overview
we have people attending from the west
coast we have people attending from
europe from
i know we've had people from india and
um i believe south asia so people from
all over i know south america
uh so thank you very much for giving us
your time
your sleep welcome thanks for having me
absolutely it was a joy
um i was given i see someone is typing
in slack so let's give that person just
another second
i was just saying thanks a lot of people
saying thanks right now in the different
chats
so i will say my own thanks again
um they are coming all the way coming
all the way but
virtually coming all the way from from
across the ocean to be here with us
just a reminder to everyone else i want
to thank eagle health alliance and scots
pizza tours
i like to remind everyone that we have
miles mcbain coming even farther than
then colin came from he's gonna be
coming from australia so uh we got
someone farther from venue
coming from australia on august 10th as
part of our week
and then august 12th through 15th we
have the conference including
rob hyneman also coming from australia
he'll be kicking off the conference
to accommodate the the time change and a
bunch of other people both
uh local and from from afar and
remember use code emi hack r and stay
tuned in september we tentatively have
planned
a talk about linux there won't be any
data that i know of in this talk i'll
just be about how to customize your
linux experience
then in october we have a someone coming
from scotland to speak to us
putting together her talk right now then
november and december we haven't
finalized yet so if anyone wants to give
a talk throw your hat into the ring for
november and december
um in november we may be putting on a
second conference the dcr conference
virtually we'll see how that goes
and maybe by january we'll see what
happens for those meetups
so we have a rest of the year mostly
planned not half planned out for the
rest of the year folks
so hopefully we'll keep that going and
since it doesn't seem like there's any
other questions hope everyone enjoys
whatever food they're eating and if
someone's eating lasagna instead of
pizza
which yeah sure um colin hopefully get
some sleep
everyone else thank you very much and i
will see all of you next month in the
meantime feel free to chat in the ny
hack our slack
ask questions hang out um we'll be
around
michael bagelmacher in new york's eating
dried mango which is from the brooklyn
co-op
it is fantastic if you ever get the
brooklyn co-op tried mango
park slope co-op i'm sorry the park
slope co-op it is fantastic
so with that another hearty thank you
and a virtual applause for colin and
we'll see all of you next month thank
you very much everybody
thanks for having me thank you bye
bye